can you guess the harry potter character
based only on a quote from the book come
on and play along with me today as we
take a harry potter quote quiz we're
gonna do 10 questions see how many we
can get right now at the end be sure you
let me know in the comments down below
how many did you get right let's jump
right in okay here we go number one it
takes a great deal of bravery to stand
up to our enemies but just as much to
stand up to our friends ah you see what
they did there that is actually a book
quote not the movie quote that is a very
popular movie quote but they changed it
a little bit at the end this is an easy
one though right guys albus
dumbledore and now let's see if i am
correct
yes albus dumbledore in harry potter and
the sorcerer's stone all right let's go
to number two we've all got both light
and dark inside us what matters is the
part we choose to act on
that's who we really are
oh i gotta think about this one for a
bit i think
i think it's serious black i think it's
serious black let's see if i'm right yes
sirius black and harry potter and the
order of the phoenix i promise guys i
did not look at the answers beforehand
only looking at them just now with you
all right moving on to number three no
good sitting around worrying about it
what's coming will come and we'll meet
it when it does ah dead gave away right
i'll give you guys a second if you're
playing along too dead giveaway though
it's gotta be
you know none other than rubius hagrid
and just to confirm let's make sure we
got it right here yes we did correct
moving on to number four you sort of
start thinking anything's possible if
you've got enough nerve
oh
man this is a
oh
why does this one i don't know like
something in the back of my mind is
saying jenny something in the back of my
mind is saying that this one is jenny
like maybe in order of the phoenix i
don't know let's take a look
yes jenny weasley in harry potter and
order phoenix got both of them right
there
man i have no idea something like in the
back of my mind i was just like wait a
second that sounds like book jenny right
there all right here we go number five
working hard is important but there is
something that matters more believing in
yourself
i honestly have no idea in this one i
have no
idea let me read it again maybe
something will happen like with that
last one where it just kind of clicked
working hard is important but there is
something that matters more
believing in yourself i mean that sounds
like something lubin would say i don't
think i'm right though but but it
definitely sounds like a looping quote
to me all right number five let's see
this was said by harry
in harry potter in the order of the
phoenix oh my goodness they got me with
that one yes when he's teaching the the
dark uh the dark army when he's teaching
dumbledore's army oh my goodness all
right so i've gotten four out of five so
far how are you doing hopefully you guys
are five for five let's move on number
six thoughts could leave deeper scars
than almost anything else
oh
dude this feels like another
oh man was that an is that an order of
the phoenix one like when snape is
teaching harry
about a cluemancy
thoughts could leave deeper scars than
almost anything else
or is it dumbledore
it's either dumbledore like when he's
teaching harry about the pensive or it's
snape i'm gonna go dumbledore i feel
like it's dumbledore and half-blood
prince
and you don't have to do the book as
well i'm just kind of doing that as i go
along because i think it's fun number
six this quote is attributed to madame
pomfrey
no
in harry potter and order of phoenix man
almost all of these are from word of the
phoenix it actually comes when ron is in
the hospital wing following the battle
at the department of mysteries man
all right that's two i've missed so far
we started off strong let's see if we
can finish strong here now because it is
not going well right now all right here
we go number seven it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live okay
come on guys
we got this easy one good one to get
back on track here none other than albus
dumbledore let's double check just to
make sure yes indeed dumbledore and this
was also in harry potter and the source
for stone or philosopher stone depending
on where you live okay moving on here we
go number eight
we are all human aren't we every human
life is worth the same
and worth saving
oh
this is prisoner of azkaban isn't it
this is prisoner of azkaban is it
serious or is it dumbledore
we've already had a couple of dumbledore
i can't i can't imagine them doing a
bunch of dumbledore we are all human
aren't we every human life is worth the
same and worth saving
uh
let's go
let's go dumbledore oh my gosh i was i
was way off
it it was kingsley shacklebolt in harry
potter and the deathly hallows man i
don't know if i'm gonna post this video
or not because you guys are gonna be
making fun of me for missing so many of
these but man that was that was a deep
one right there kingsley shacklebolt in
harry potter and deathly hallows
man okay here we go number nine if you
want to know what a man's like take a
good look at how he treats his inferiors
not his equals
dude i know this one i know this one i
know this one i know this one
if you want to know what a man's like
take a good look at how he treats his
inferiors not as equals i'm pretty sure
that's serious uh talking about uh i
think he's actually talking about malfoy
and his treatment of house elves let's
take a look number nine yes sirius black
in harry potter and the goblet of fire
right and it wasn't uh it wasn't malfoy
it was actually uh barty crouch that uh
hermione hermione was upset and serious
was that that's when that quote happened
all right here we go number 10 the final
one here again don't forget to let me
know in the comments how many did you
get correct i'm sure you guys beat me
i'm sure you did not googling though you
can't cheat you got to go for memory
number 10 happiness can be found even in
the darkest of times if one only
remembers to turn on the light see some
of these are very popular in the movie
like that one right there
immediately jumps to my mind from the
movie
i'll give you guys a second of course
once again we've got our man albus
dumbledore here let's just double check
to make sure yes indeed and this one was
in
prisoner of azkaban
yes got it right prisoner of azkaban all
right let's look back here we missed
let's see one two and three so we got
seven out of ten not terrible i wanted
to do much better but again i didn't
look beforehand so i just wanted to take
it naturally see what happened hope you
guys enjoyed this video as always thank
you all so much for watching and i'll
talk to you again soon